joining me now Victor Davis Hansen
Hoover institution senior fellow Victor
we call it uh the fog of War this is the
fog of a lot more than War here there's
an enormous amount of propaganda you see
it on Tik Tok I wouldn't doubt that the
Chinese are pushing some of this but uh
this is now a dangerous moment do we
have a serious Administration to
confront
it yeah I think people in the Middle
East wanted to know whether the Afghan
humiliation the Invasion the Chinese
balloon or open border was an aberration
or did we really lose deterrence and
have adopted fullscale appeasement and
now they look at uh Biden's failed
Middle East effort the idea of giving
Iran $6 billion which he hasn't
cancelled the restoration of money to
the Palestinians and by the way I might
add the message that's going out in the
Middle East is if you have a lie that
the Israelis hit a hospital and you prom
ated all over the Western and the Middle
Eastern worlds and you get protests and
the American president
humiliated uh because he has no
deterrence then he will give you a $100
million dild and the funny thing is that
in a weird way Laura we're basically
saying to the Palestinians go kill
Israeli children and women and we're
going to reward out with $100 million
and what's even worse is we're saying to
the world if that missile that was
intended to kill Jewish civilians in Tel
Aviv had not missed the Target and
accidentally hurt some or killed some
Palestinians then we wouldn't even give
them money probably we only giving money
CU we're paranoid they're angry over a
lie that uh that the Israelis did
something but it if it wasn't a lie and
they had really killed Israelis as
intended we probably would have said
well that's okay we don't really mind
that and so it's really a morally
bankrupt Administration I hate to say
that because we all have have to be
stick together but when you look at what
they're doing to our troops in Iraq and
you look at what's going on here on our
campuses and in New York and even at the
capital you get the the impression where
this is much worse than 1980 with Jimmy
Carter you have a complete meltdown of
us deterrence throughout the world it's
very dangerous very dangerous in the
next 15 months in general and
specifically in the next
week and Victor we're watching scenes of
some of these
uh protests breaking out in New York
right now um so far they seem to be
peaceful but that many people in the
dark tempers flaring we don't know
anything's possible Victor I want to ask
about this money that Biden's going to
be after tomorrow night he's going to go
to the nation with a teleprompter and
he's going to say we need this 100
billion plus which will be 500 billion
before you blank for both Ukraine and uh
Israel that that is critical money and
and we need it for the stability of the
world for peace I wouldn't be surprised
if he didn't call it some type of you
know investment in the future uh how
will that go down with the American
people I think it won't go down too well
because there's such an asymmetry we
never told Ukraine there's a cycle of
violence you can't retaliate when Putin
comes in we we we always say dis
discount uh Putin's nuclear threats that
will never happen he would never dare
but yet we Iran doesn't have the bomb
and we're told be careful about Iran
they're threatening us so there's such
an asymmetry to the reactions of both of
these wars and you know we never said to
the ukrainians we we don't want you to
do this and and when you hit a
infrastructure or Bridge or something we
want you to phone civilians and get them
out of the way so there's only one
explanation I'm afraid and that is
there's an endemic anti-Semitism in the
asymmetry that we treat our closest Ally
Israel versus you know a friend but
Ukraine doesn't have the relationship
and we don't apply the same restrictions
on Ukraine than we do on Israel and it
makes no sense and to ask money yeah
they're not a they're not lying about us
shaking us yeah they're an it's just I
don't think it's going to sell
especially when you have a president
that's incoherent and can't articulate
what the uh the prop Victor we got to go
we got breaking new is for we got to go
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
Subs subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else